all right this is it people
yeah
that's right i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message and for the
last time ever today
on this december 14 2021 i am
broadcasting to you live from los
angeles california
we are getting the f out of here right
after this right when we finish this
live stream the studio will be
disassembled i have packers packing the
house almost everything is gone i gave
away half of everything that i own and
we are getting the hell out of here and
we are moving to the free state of
california every inch of this studio
right now is covered in boxes and
packing material i got bubble wrap to
keep me distracted i've got packing
peanuts
it's very exciting time we cannot wait
to get out of here as a matter of fact
michael my producer this morning he was
picking up starbucks and
some breakfast for everybody got into a
fight with a local barista over a mask
so we're going out in a blaze of glory
we are psyched and ready to roll
guys do me a favor if you have not done
it already subscribe to our youtube
channel rumble channel of course we're
live streaming on blaze tv oh and by the
way in honor of florida and the big move
i put up a video uh this morning on
twitter uh sort of a behind the scenes
of the studio situation
but if you subscribe to the reuben
report locals community uh we're only
doing this till the end of the year and
this is the best deal we got we're never
gonna have a better deal than this you
get three months free if you do an
annual subscription you don't have to
put in a code or anything else that's
just in honor of uh what's going on here
with this big move to florida so you can
go to reubenreport.locals.com
and we are doing a q a today and yes it
is mostly about the move there were a
lot of questions people want to know
about my past
about my future and all of that that
good stuff and yes we're hiring there's
a ton of good stuff going on we are
going to save america i have nothing
better to do than save this country and
that's what i'm gonna do uh and i'm
gonna start doing it in the great state
of florida before i get to that though
guys i want to talk to you about jen
yourself because you know you want to
look your best when you're in a great
place
like florida and hey why don't you take
a look in the mirror do you mirror the
mirror
that was that was my long island accent
just burst forth my whole life's coming
together right now take a look in the
mirror
see those bags under your eyes imagine
them gone well guys you can get rid of
that puffiness just in time for the
holiday season introducing genius cell
plants stem cell therapy for bags and
puffiness under the eyes uh you know
i've had bad guys under i've had bags
under my eyes over the years and i don't
have them anymore why is that my
assistant helen even told me that she's
been enjoying januselle products that we
received so so much that she's sharing
them with family and friends better yet
geniuselles immediate effects product
you'll see results in the first 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back hurry guys
only two weeks left for the januselle
christmas and holiday season sale jen
yourself's most popular package is sixty
percent off at lovejanyusell.com dave
treat yourself and a loved one to the
absolute best skin care in the world
just go to lovegenyasel.com
dave and enter my special promo code
dave for an extra special holiday
present order now and get free priority
shipping for delivery by christmas
that's love g-e-n-u-c-e-l
dot com slash dave lovejandycell.com
dave and now back to me all right before
i get into the q a
i want to show you
a perfect example of why i am leaving
the dystopian
nightmare of california and moving to
the free
state of florida ron desantis who is the
governor of florida who is a good decent
man trying to fight the tide of nonsense
and authoritarian lunacy that is
sweeping across this country he is
fighting to keep his state free and i'm
going to damn well do everything i can
to help him well he was on laura
ingram's show last night talking about
the stark difference
between california and florida and i'm
fairly certain he was talking directly
to me through the tube take a look
really quickly on this issue of mask
mandates i know you've rejected them
across the board
what's your reaction tonight to both
newsome and california and hoco in new
york going back to mass mandates
with this omicron which seems to be
thankfully so far
a mild virus
and that's the data we have at least so
far on that what's your what's your
reaction to the blue states reaction to
uh to this
well what are we on like day 700 of the
15 days to slow the spread the fact of
the matter is i think we've learned you
give these people an inch they will
never let go they're going to take a
mile they are going to restrict they're
going to mandate they're going to lock
you down and we cannot accept that
obviously in florida we do not accept it
so there's no reason to be restricting
or mandating anybody
throughout our country and the fact that
this is still going on in these blue
states and may even intensify over the
coming weeks and months
it just shows you if you value your
freedom
in 2022 if you're in those states you
need to make your voice heard and you
got to do a change of direction because
i fear that they're going to continue to
do this until they suffer at the ballot
box yeah new york has now a higher
case rate
than florida governor new york city new
york city just to be specific about that
yeah and so here's the thing laura it's
a seasonal pattern southern states have
a different season the northern states
have there going through their season
mandates and restrictions have not been
effective but they've been very costly
and i think the proof is in the pudding
you have people that want to come to
florida to vacation buy homes you don't
have the opposite where people are
leaving free states to try to go to new
york or some of these other places
god i can't wait to get out of here yeah
everything he said there is true how
refreshing is it these days to hear
someone that plainly speaks the truth
that doesn't want to rule over you that
just wants to create the conditions so
that the people that live in his state
can live free that mandates don't work
that we know all of this nonsense
lockdowns don't work you can keep people
in masks forever it's seasonal and it's
gonna be like the flu and some people
will get a little sicker and some people
won't and will get hurt immunity and all
of those things it's just plain
spoken truth i cannot wait to get out of
here can you guys feel it yeah yeah i'm
i'm literally gonna explode the end of
this show is just me spontaneously
combusting and then they'll just take my
mush to
to florida oh my god and by the way
desantis he's lost a little weight which
that kind of hints at perhaps a
presidential run could that be i feel
like they always try to get fit right
before a presidential run which speaking
of that i saw a picture of uh of trump
on the golf course a day or two ago it
looks like he's lost like 40 pounds so
who knows what's going on all right guys
we got a gajillion questions here real
quick i want to talk to you about canva
you know making content is an essential
part of what my team and i do to keep
this show going but it hasn't always
been a seamless creative process from
video social media our website in our
community to merchandise business cards
and even my book cover our design skills
have been challenged in ways we could
have never imagined fortunately we have
found canva pro and now we can design
anything like a pro on any device canva
pro is a design platform
that empowers you to create and share
stunning content in just a couple clicks
choose from thousands of templates that
are easy to customize or start from
scratch canva pro has endless premium
fonts photos videos and so much more
that add personality and edge to your
designs and designing together has never
been easier sharing editing and
commenting in real time canva pro helps
teams stay organized and on the same
page no more misplaced files or tedious
back and forth plus you and four
teammates can unlock everything canva
pro has to offer for just 12.99 a month
and with canva pro's content planner
you'll save time planning creating and
posting social media content as well
pause schedule posts and edit them
anytime design like a pro with canva pro
right now you can get a free 45-day
extended trial and use my promo code
just go to canva.me slash ruben to get
your free 45-day extended trial that's
c-a-n-v-a dot
e slash reuben canva dot me slash reuben
and now back to me all right here we go
the last show
from los angeles and then we blow up the
place uh super spouse says moving just
in time gruesome newsom has us back in
masks tomorrow if the vaccines work what
is going on so in case you didn't pick
up what laura ingram was asking desantis
there
they are starting an indoor
mask mandate once again throughout all
of california now la where i live for
now
for the next 24 hours
has had this indoor mass mandate
virtually everywhere so you walk into
starbucks you get into a fight if you're
this guy if you go to a supermarket you
get yelled at without a mask if you're
this guy uh you know it's just it's just
been an abject disaster here we know
those things don't work and yes to your
point it seems to me at this point that
the people who are the most pro-vaccine
are also the biggest anti-vaxxers at
some level if you believe that vaccines
work the way they were promised to work
then you would not care if someone else
was vaccinated or not if you believed
and we were all told at first you know
you're going to get the vaccine
everything's going to be fine it's going
to give you 100 coverage we're going to
open up the country we're good to go now
if that had been the case it would not
matter you'd get vaccinated and then if
10 people around you didn't want to get
vaccinated well first off it doesn't
mean that they're automatically sick
that happens to be sort of the way
people are looking at it right now like
somehow you're either vaccinated and
that means you're clean or you're
unvaccinated and that means you're sick
and it's like no there are plenty of
perfectly healthy people who have not
gotten vaccinated who are good decent
people trying to make mental medical
decisions for themselves perhaps they do
exercise and eat right and get sunlight
things of that nature
but if you believe that if you took the
vaccine
and it works well then you wouldn't care
what someone else does okay but we know
obviously in fact check me youtube or
delete this video if you think i'm lying
the vaccines do not work as promised the
meme very quickly changed from you'll
get 100 coverage to oh you won't get as
sick if you get the vaccine oh but also
now we kind of figured out that after
three months uh the vaccines aren't
quite as strong and after six months
they're really not as strong so you want
that second shot and you want that
booster shot and you want that fourth
booster blah blah blah blah blah
so the point is
to desantis's point this has very little
to do with anything other than control
you absolutely should do whatever it is
that you think is right whatever it is
that you think works for you and your
family and your loved ones and all of
those things and why do we not talk
about the rest of the health stuff like
working out why do we not talk about
losing weight why do we not talk about
eating right never has fouchy ever
talked about any of those things there
was a study that i saw in the last
couple days that one of the reasons that
kovit is spreading more amongst
obese people is because it's attacking
fat cells like there's all sorts of
stuff that maybe we need to know more
about but as a general rule uh living a
somewhat healthy lifestyle is probably
good for you so yes it is absolutely
insane
that he is instigating this uh mask
mandate again tomorrow and it's
perfectly fitting that i'm getting the
out of here that was my one f-bomb
for the day i promise patrick says when
you wrestle your first alligator will
you follow a catch and release policy or
will you use it to make loafers for you
and david
now i want to be clear about something
here first off as i said yesterday i've
always loved florida we always
vacationed in florida my folks have a
little uh winter place down in florida
and it's they've got a little moat
behind the place and alligators go by
i've always i think i've been seeing the
same alligator probably you know
alligators give me a average lifespan on
an alligator would you alligators live
for a freaking long time so i'm pretty
sure i've been seeing this one alligator
just go back and forth past my parents
little condo for very pretty much i've
been going there for 45 years my whole
life alligators live 30 to 50 years so
it could be the same gator it could be
maybe it isn't i'll have to ask him when
i get down there but sometimes he comes
up on the banks and just kind of hangs
out there and i've gotten as close to
maybe 15 feet i do know by the way and i
know a lot of you are concerned one of
the things you got to know about
alligators is that if an alligator is
chasing you this is an important piece
of knowledge that i know even though
i've been living in california but this
shows that i've vacationed in florida
before if an alligator chases you what
you don't want to do is run straight
because they're very fast what you want
to do is if you kind of run like a
zigzag like one of these michaels is
very important miami mike you want to go
like this or run in circles because then
they have to drag their tail and that
will slow them down because it's hard to
drag the tail but if you're bam that way
they can follow you so what the hell is
the question uh yes oh will i make
alligator loafers no i'm going to be
very pro-alligator i love alligators i
got these two alligator pictures right
here i've always enjoyed the reptile i'm
going to go to gatorland i can't wait to
be there oh and in the house that we're
buying actually speaking of alligators
the guy that we're buying from he's big
florida guy and uh there's a whole wall
that's like alligator wallpaper so i'll
put i'll post a picture of that so
you'll see that there you go uh michael
says you mentioned yesterday that elon
musk was among those fleeing california
and taking their employees with them are
there any plans to have the person of
the year in the new studio for an
interview also dodge coin to the moon
look i would absolutely love to sit down
with elon musk
oddly you know for all the circles that
we sort of travel in that are somewhat
similar and kind of overlapping
i've never met him we've never
communicated in any way
you know i've got enough friends sort of
somewhat in his world so i would love to
because even though he moved to austin
so he moved to texas and he took tesla
there i mean think about it you still
got this idiot
this complete
buffoon that fake indian woman elizabeth
warren tweeting about how evil elon musk
is every day this guy who is sending
electric cars to the
to orbit just because he can the guy
who's gonna get us to mars the guy who's
building electric cars down here
building underground railroads like all
of this stuff and she's produced nothing
ever other than she pretended to be
native american to get a job but they
always go after the people that produce
this is sort of what atlas shrugged is
all about right um
so i would love to sit down with elon
musk i'd love to know what his
considerations were when he said hey i'm
going to take my company and move them
to texas as opposed to tennessee as
opposed to florida as opposed to some of
the other red states that he could have
done that um so stay tuned we'll we'll
work on it uh clickaholics says what
will you miss most about california and
what do you look forward to most about
florida what will i miss most about
california i mean
look as i said yesterday we've had a
very good life here i came here we came
here eight or nine years ago it's it'll
be nine years in about a month that we
came here we had nothing like we had i
think ten or fifteen thousand dollars
between the two of us um we've really
struggled for a while like we took a lot
of risks those things usually paid off
like we grew companies i built and sold
a tech company in the time that i was
here the reuben report continued to
explode like i've lived a really good
life while i've been here and i will i
will look fondly
on all of that it's what's happened to
the state in the last couple years and a
lot of people that have been here for a
long time have said this has been slowly
going on for for a really long time you
really don't know what it used to be
like
and that's just fine
um what i'll miss most honestly i mean
this is going to sound like the end of
lord of the rings but i'll miss the
friends you know like the other hobbits
i'll miss the friends because uh you
know i mentioned the other night we had
dinner with dennis prager and his wife
and larry elder and his girlfriend and
patricia heaton and her and her husband
dave and abigail schreier and her
husband zach and uh and marissa the ceo
of prageru and her husband and like i've
met all of these really cool people uh
who've been up my inner circle here and
they're all here still and everyone's
thinking about moving um
and i don't say any of that to name drop
like oh i had dinner with these people
it's more like i've had i've had
a great network here a great network of
really cool interesting people because
there are people like that here it's
just that they're in the minority and
it's getting worse and their their
influence our influence to change things
here just seems like it's diminishing
every day so i'll i'll miss the people i
suppose and i'll miss the weather a
little bit but yeah florida's got great
weather too and i'll survive in august
like i don't know maybe i'll go
somewhere for a couple weeks or i'll
survive like it will be okay what do i
look forward to most about in florida i
mean that that's easy it's life
life is in florida i'm telling you we've
been there a couple times over the last
few uh months because we were we were
going initially to look for a house then
i wanted to bring my team so that they
could come and figure out how we were
going to build out the studio and they
could find apartments and all that stuff
and it's like another planet like i i
really feel like i'm moving to another
country this isn't this doesn't feel
like if 10 years ago i had been like ah
you know what i wrapped up everything i
want to do here in california i'm moving
to florida i'm moving back to new york
or whatever it'll be like oh okay
there's some marginal differences but
now it feels like i'm moving to another
country a place that is governed by a
completely different set of rules than
this ridiculous place known as
california
and and what i'm looking forward to is
being out and about and seeing people
again and i'm not kidding literally
seeing people smile you do not see
people smile here because you cannot see
their faces and when we've gone out in
in florida restaurants are packed
there's life on the streets you know
things aren't boarded up everywhere uh
and just to be part of that so what i'm
really excited about is that
i think there that creatively for me and
this show and all that like i think it's
going to be it's going to be juiced up
because i don't like i've told you this
a couple times like you know when in the
morning when i look at the stories and
i'm like ah gavin newsom did this oh
california did this oh la's run by a
bunch of morons it's like that's a
little myopic because i have people all
over the world that watch this and you
know what i'm going to just let
california go sorry
i'm done with you there's nothing else i
could do you can come knocking on my
door one day and go oh no we turned it
around and i'll be very happy for that
um but i want to focus on good and i
want to focus on things that we can
build and do better with and save this
freaking country and that's what i'm
going to freaking do
in florida philip says
months ago during their first backstage
after moving to nashville ben shapiro
made the comment about you moving and
said we are going to grow old together
in florida does that mean mean he is
once again proven right so i did a
backstage with them right as i think it
was the last day that they were in la
something like that
and uh and shapiro was mocking me
because i was staying and i said but you
know noel said he was gonna stay and i'm
gonna fight and larry elder and we'll do
it and yada yada
and ben was just like yeah yeah we're
gonna grow it all together in florida i
can see it and yes he was right he was
right like it's actually
true uh ben got one right there you go
ben congratulations um
look i was on ben's radio show this
morning which i think they'll replay or
post on youtube a little bit later today
and we get into it a little bit more
but ben's inclination was right you know
i live not too far from where the daily
wire studios used to be probably about a
mile and a half or so and they're on the
main drag over here and the building
that at one time they had 75 people
working in and they did such a great job
with these studios they were beautiful
they were state of the art the whole
building on the inside was gorgeous very
nondescript on the outside but they
poured so much money into this they had
expanded into the building next door
they had huge plans then all hell break
broke loose with the lockdowns and the
race riots and all the crazy nonsense
and it was right so much of it was right
on the street where they were which is
very close to where i used to live which
is partly why i moved into this house
because it was a little further away i
thought it would buy me some time and i
suppose that it did
um but when you pass that now the
building that they used to be in it's
boarded up and you could just tell no
one's renting this freaking thing no
one's gonna be like yes i'd like to
start a business
at that on that main street where
everything else is boarded up and
restaurants can't stay open and there's
garbage everywhere and it looks like an
abject nightmare like no one's gonna do
it so think about what california did so
i'm talking to you gavin newsom you
bastard and i'm talking to you eric
garcetti is even still our mayor nobody
even knows anymore like where are these
ridiculous people it's like you guys you
ruined the state and you ruined the city
75 good hard-working people
who were productive members of society
and a company in this case the daily
wire that is worth millions and millions
of dollars took their business out and
now i'm taking a whole bunch of people
and another company that's worth
millions of dollars and we are getting
out of here that's on you guys so good
luck good luck with your gender studies
and good luck with your critical race
theory and good luck with your high
taxes and high regulation and see where
that gets you but i'm not going to waste
a lot of time talking about it uh kathy
says how is clyde taking the move i
think we got a couple pictures here
here's clyde last night so the the
movers put out that we normally don't
have red carpet running through the
house although i am a big star you know
big star big star uh but they put some
it's raining so they put some uh red
carpet out uh that's clyde uh late night
that was last night as we were moving
stuff out he was kind of trying to
figure out what the hell's going on here
uh but he's been he's been pretty chill
and then later in the evening let's put
the next one up yeah that was when he
had just sort of had it at that point
and cashed out he does have a bed up in
our bedroom we haven't packed that up
yet um but uh you can see boxes
everywhere and packing up but he's been
good he's ready he's ready and we're
gonna have a big yard in the other place
and i just can't wait to to get him out
of here and just try something new let's
just try something new clyde is down for
an adventure
uh brad says how convenient
that you are oh sorry how confident are
you that the exodus from california
isn't carrying with it the voting
tendencies that are running the state
into the ground okay this is the
bajillion dollar question
because this has happened in the past
when there are these migrations
what you see happen is all these people
from san francisco they ruin san
francisco with their ridiculous lefty
high tax policies
the education goes to homelessness
you all know that and then what do they
do they move to places like austin where
they often vote in the same stupid stuff
that they were escaping so this is legit
and what's interesting is i got i got
literally thousands literally thousands
of messages yesterday welcome to florida
can't wait for you to be here blah blah
blah but every now and again you get one
and it's like people are like but just
don't bring those stupid policies with
you and i get it i i not only do i get
it i am going to really uh be doing
everything i can to make sure that
people who come to florida after i'm
there helping defend all of the good
stuff that florida man has been up to
florida man who you we used to all make
fun of who maybe he got some right
as he was wrestling the alligators um
i'm gonna do everything i can to make
sure that when people come they know why
they're coming right that's what that's
what the battle of ideas is all about
you can show people there's a better way
of doing things and if you voted a
certain way for sam in san francisco for
30 years or in la for 20 years if you
voted a certain way and then you're
leaving because everything is collapsing
and that is what's happening well then
don't bring that stupid lefty nonsense
to the other places respect that those
people maybe knew something and that's
very hard for liberals and lefties in in
general to go ah you know maybe i had a
little something to do with the collapse
of this thing um so you know what i'll
do a little maya culpa here maybe the
dave rubin of seven years ago had a
little something to do with this when i
was pushing some of those ideas and i
was a bernie supporter and everything
else but i'm going to go there and
defend those ideals that are keeping
that state in great shape and and that's
the best
the best that people can do is
understand why you're free why you're
flourishing why you're thriving and
communicate that to other people so when
all the mugged liberals who are decent
people who maybe didn't care about
politics that enough
that much or just went along with the
crowd when they show up at your state
because everything that they love has
been destroyed they don't do the same
thing they go ah you know i better look
in the mirror for just a second and i
better realize that oh maybe it is
that conservatives aren't all racist
maybe these people aren't all bigots and
homophobes maybe they do get a little
something maybe the words freedom and
liberty
maybe they actually mean something maybe
rights mean something maybe the state is
not god maybe some of that is something
and those are the ideas that i'm gonna
really be pushing for and making sure
people understand that stuff i promise
you
miles says for those interested in
working for you and your organization or
company in florida where can they apply
so look we are hiring i am going to save
a lot of money by being in florida we
crunch the numbers on on income tax and
i don't need a freaking yacht okay so
we're going to expand right now we're
looking at least for an associate
producer but probably much more so if
you're in marketing if you're in i.t if
you're in production
whatever you dig me and you got some
skills i don't know you want to teach me
how to wrestle alligators whatever it is
email us jobs reubenreport.com but i do
want to be clear about something i will
not hire you because of your skin color
and i don't care what gender you are
sexuality okay if you have skills if you
have passion if you want to work hard if
you want to grow if you want to do
something with value you could work for
me but i if you think i'm going to hire
you because of your skin color no and i
don't care who you sleep with i know
that's old school i'm old school okay i
want people who want to work hard so
jobs at reubenreport.com and by the way
it's not just us that are hiring locals
is down in miami uh we're opening
offices there we're building on a fully
functioning tv studio so all our locals
creators if they're in town can do shows
so you can email jobs locals.com if
you're interested in that and we're
gonna we're gonna blow it up man
joe says are you planning to change the
time of the live show since you're gonna
be on easter standard time joe thank you
for asking because i would have forgot
to mention yes
we are making a change so we do this
show right now it's uh right now it's
about 11 30 a.m
uh here on the pacific coast uh in
california time uh so we obviously been
doing this show at 11 a.m pacific uh for
a while now i like the 11am pacific it
lets me set up my day properly so i can
do all my work and meetings and calls
and book stuff and just all of that
stuff i'm an early riser these days like
6am so i have about four or five hours
worth of work in the morning then we do
the show and then i can do tv hits or
whatever else i might be doing so yes
we're going to keep the show at 11 a.m
but it's going to be 11 a.m eastern
which is 11 a.m eastern is which way am
i going in my head right now 11 a.m
eastern is 2 p.m pacific yeah so we're
gonna be on it no no no sorry it's 8 a.m
pacific
see these are the things that i'm gonna
have to
learn as florida man okay uh we are
going to be on at 11 a.m eastern which
will be 8 a.m pacific going forward um i
think that's just better for my team
it's just a better way getting the day
going getting everything we want to do
in order uh oh and i should mention you
know i said it yesterday uh but as of
today this is our last show here closing
up shop
and then we're going dark basically
through the end of the year now i had
plans already originally and this is
what we do every year we were going dark
for christmas week i don't want my guys
working from christmas to new year's
anyway it's a nice time to take off you
shouldn't be paying attention to
politics you should be with family and
enjoying the season and and the spirit
of christmas and all that good stuff
but we are going dark a little bit early
because of the move so i won't have a
studio for the next two weeks then when
we get to florida we're building out an
awesome studio i promise you it's going
to be really freaking awesome but i will
be in a makeshift makeshift studio in
the house for a little bit so you'll
have to bear with us for that but i have
confidence that we're going to do
something nice and i'm definitely going
to have to get a white linen suit you
know that's definitely going to be part
of this with a nice pink shirt big
lapels the whole thing little uh little
aqua
pocket square you know the whole the
whole thing very miami vice
so yes we will be on at 11 a.m eastern
when we are back and uh we'll be in a
temp studio and then our big build-out
studio and what i will do also over the
next couple weeks because i don't want
to just go mia on you obviously it's
going to be it's going to be nutty with
with physically moving and just like all
the things we're coordinating but i'm
going to do a bunch of video stuff on
locals probably exclusively for the
locals community i feel like these have
been the people
that have been supporting me the most
directly people that i have like a real
relationship with who i try to respond
to every day and everything else so
again if you want to join us
reubenreport.locals.com and if you sign
up now through the end of the year you
get three months free which we're going
to end at the end of the year then we're
not doing that again the three months
that this just purely an honor of uh
getting the hell out of here uh all
right sue says what encouragement do you
have for those of us that can't leave
california just yet planning to leave
very soon but stuck here in the bay area
for the moment praying for a safe
journey for you well first off thanks on
that look i get it i kid you not every
single person that i know that lives in
los angeles is trying to plot their exit
one of the reasons that david and i
decided to leave now
is because we don't have kids yet we're
working on it i hope i can share some uh
some great life updates with you guys
soon
but obviously once you have kids it
makes things much more complex so i have
a lot of friends that have kids you got
kids in grade school you got kids in
high school it's like it's hard to move
whole families it's not just about you
figuring out can you work in this new
place or is your job remote or all that
kids after school sports are i don't
even know if they're allowed to do that
in california anymore but like if the
more entrenched you are the bigger your
family is and the more you entrenched
you are in a community maybe your
parents or siblings adult siblings aunts
uncles blah blah blah it's like i get
why it's very hard to leave this so i
viewed this as our best chance to get
out i also sense that the real estate
market is going to absolutely collapse
here because nobody's moving here so i
also felt like i didn't want to get you
know crushed on the house here and then
have to move to miami or anywhere in
florida really where the real estate
market is exploding so you have to pay a
lot right now
to get in there in the first place but i
i get the stuck feeling it's not a great
feeling i would just say start
doing the work whatever that means to
you whether that means starting to look
for work in florida starting to work
remote for a company that's based in
florida talking to your spouse talking
to your kids like start laying some of
the groundwork this decision for me was
not easy because i've got a bunch of
employees and i had to talk to everybody
and really make sure everybody wanted to
go now i was lucky everyone did want to
go but like you gotta
plan that whether it's your family or
your work life or whatever it is like
start doing the things it's not just
that one day you're gonna be like i'm
getting the hell out of here and then
you grab your bag and go like that's a
pretty unique experience if you could do
that so just sort of really think about
it seriously i mean this is something
that jordan peterson used to talk about
when we were on tour off and a lot of
people would ask a question like i'm
really unhappy at my job what do i do
and you know he would say that a lot of
people would come to him with that when
he was a clinical therapist and they'd
be like i'm quitting my job i'm just
quitting my job and he would always say
well that's crazy have you thought about
how you're going to pay for rent how are
you going to pay for food how are you
going to pay for your kids et cetera et
cetera he's like you have to take a
little time suck it up and i get it it
sucks you're in the bay area i mean the
bay area is a nightmare right it's just
a nightmare if you're around san
francisco that's not to say there aren't
some nice places there and i hope one
day if they ever let me back in
california i'd love to go back to napa
right i'd love to go back to sonoma wine
country
but i honestly don't know that i'm ever
going to come back here i really don't
but do the things that you have to do in
your life so that you can get out
before it's too late and and i just
the thing is you will flourish you will
flourish when you go i can feel it i
know it i know so many people who have
left and i don't know anyone do you guys
know anyone like anyone that's left and
been like oh i should have stayed in
cali
i missed the taxes i missed the homeless
i miss the drug use i miss the shitty
schools i mix miss the crack pavement
and side streets and
crazy here says somebody's going to buy
your house open the garage and say did
they shoot porn flicks in here
well
i'm not a trial here okay
no first off this is my this is my
office actually so my other studio that
you guys all remember that actually we
had built out that was fully the garage
the new studio that we're building is
also going to be in the garage it's
going to be significantly bigger than
this and we're building offices and a
whole bunch of other stuff this house
was pretty cool because when we walked
in this was built in what's behind me
right now these shelves were built in as
an office we put the lighting in there
obviously we decked them out and all
that whole thing but my garage is pretty
much a garage so i don't think they'll
walk in there and say did they shoot
horn flicks in there i guess they could
walk in here and think we've got great
lighting you know we're having a good
time around here there's nobody's
complaining uh next up kimberly says uh
will you have space for a garden at your
new place i bet you could grow almost
anything in florida yeah we're getting a
lot of land
which i'm super psyched about you know
here in la you really can't get land so
i've had my four planters upstairs on
the roof and i got uh basil and i got
tomatoes and i have a little orange tree
which you want to know a sign you know
how the universe talks to you sometimes
so basically for about five years david
and i have tried with different citrus
trees to to grow lemons or limes oranges
grapefruit etc but because we didn't
have a lot of land we were always trying
to do it out of pots so we'd get you
know nice big pots and we get like a
decent-sized citrus tree at home depot
or lowe's or whatever and over the years
we've probably tried to grow maybe 10 or
15 different uh citrus trees into fruit
bearing trees and it has never worked
here and i know you know generally
citrus trees don't want to be grown in
pots but you absolutely can do it you
can do it in a very small pot even in
your kitchen with enough sunlight anyway
for all these years we could just never
get one to thrive finally in the last
two weeks i've had the citrus tree
upstairs
and it's putting out oranges left and
right like that is a sign man go to
florida the tree is telling me leave me
here there's nothing else you can do for
me i have borne fruit for you now go to
a place where fruit is free and
bountiful and that place is florida the
citrus capital world and by the way i
love citrus i'm a citrus guy love
oranges love lime
lemon grapefruit love it so i'm very
excited uh yes so i will build out an
awesome garden i can't wait to do that
um and like we could do like just really
really cool like much bigger things i
think maybe we'll get a chicken coop
again i'm psyched man are there chickens
in florida you can have chickens in
florida right the gators probably love
the chickens um actually i went to
gatorland once when i was a kid i think
i was about 12 years old we took a trip
down to orlando we went to disney and
epcot and that whole thing and then we
went to gatorland and they it was
incredible i'll never forget this i
don't even know if they do this anymore
i'm sure aspca couldn't have been happy
with them but
they had a big chicken wire going across
like a pond and they put chickens
hanging on the wires and then gators
would just jump out
chomp the chickens bring them down
feathers flying all over blood it was
awesome man i can't wait to get out of
here cooper
dave when you find a favorite bar in
florida let us know so we can shout you
a drink yes i will meet with people
again i promise you i love doing meetups
with my locals community we will go to
bars we will drink margaritas we will
drink mojitos whatever else they're
serving in florida don't love the orange
wine i don't but i'll i will try it
again you know they make wine out of
oranges i think in florida i will i am
down to try it again because that's how
much i want to become florida i want
florida inside me you understand
galersch says i don't know where gavin
newsom lives but before you leave
california you should get a picture of
clyde peeing on a tree in his front yard
it won't hurt newsom or the tree so it's
mostly symbolic i mean at that point i
would just you know have him take a dump
and a bag and i'd throw it at the window
um but uh yeah i don't like avenues i
wouldn't bother why would i want clyde
to have to go there and smell around
newsom like he smells like sulfur clyde
doesn't want that
anastasia says will you do any live
chats over the two two and a half weeks
that you will not be doing the reuben
report with your locals community yeah
so that's where i'm going to be putting
most of the stuff we have one or two
videos some fun things a couple people
welcoming me to florida that we're going
to put up on youtube but yeah i'm going
to be doing more live chats with you
guys i'm going to be doing more live
streams in the locals community and just
kind of staying in touch with you guys i
know it's weird because you disappear
for like a little bit and people could
forget about you so yeah so
reubenreport.locals.com as i said three
months free if you sign up annually
right now and i will absolutely stay in
touch with you guys for sure and we're
going to set up live meet and greets
down in florida actually i just told my
agents yesterday i want to do a huge
live event in florida uh hopefully in
january just to like kick off like here
we are
let's save this state
byrne says are you going to change your
hairstyle in order to adapt to the
florida humidity this is a big one this
is a big one for me because you know
humidity what it does is it weighs down
the hair now here in in los angeles in
california we have low humidity here you
can do a lot with the hair you can get
it as high as you want you can wave it
around and then you can spray it in such
a way that it's pretty much not going to
move on you fart it's different it's
humid you're going to be getting a lower
hair you're going to be getting product
dripping into your eye especially in the
summer season so i'm gonna have to talk
to my people about that about what are
we gonna do like should i shave it off
with is that it go into my no keep it's
it's too much of a train it's a
trademark it's a trademark i'm gonna
keep it as long as i can but we're gonna
need gorilla glue i don't know what
we're gonna do but we will we will do
something to make sure that the dave
rubin that you know and love
it he's the same dave rubin in florida
but he's better you know what i mean
he's better dave rubin uh because maybe
there's some sort of alligator oils i
could be putting in my hair whatever it
is we're gonna find it mike says
congratulations on your decision to
leave the communist state of california
dave continued success in the land of
the free and the brave that's not a
question but i appreciate the kind words
and candace says you have helped push me
over the edge and i've decided i'm
leaving as well what's the first thing
you want to do in free florida
well first off i'm thrilled to hear that
i got a lot of messages from people
yesterday saying hey i'm thinking about
leaving or like you just like got like
this like stuck in my head now and i got
to talk to my wife or husband or all
that kind of stuff so i'm glad i'm glad
like if you love freedom if you love
america if you love having some capacity
to make a decision over your life like
get out of new york putting in vaccine
mandates and masks again and get out of
california and let you guys can have it
like we're conceding it to you people
okay
you social justice lefty marxist
communist freaks you can have california
have it with all your diversity and have
it with all of your nonsense and you
will destroy it but have it but you
can't have what we want to pick one all
right so you can have it i'm letting it
go i'm letting you go callie and i ain't
coming back
that's it guys that's it this is uh this
is it um
what can i say to you what can i say
that i haven't said already um well i
guess i sort of said this yesterday but
i just want to uh tell you guys one more
time just how appreciative i am that so
many of you i mean literally hundreds of
thousands millions of you are on this
adventure with me the amount of messages
i get of support
um that that you welcome me into your
homes or onto your phones
every day even just for a few minutes to
to offer a little sanity into your day
like trust me you guys are paying it
right back to me because if i was just
talking into the ether
i probably wouldn't be doing this like
we're all keeping each other saying i
hope that you will see that with this
move that we're doing that that these
aren't just ideas
like you can put your life into motion
and set it up for great things like i
know
that great things are coming i'm not
afraid to say that i'm not afraid to
jinx it because i know that we are going
to flourish in all kinds of ways and i
mean that for me i mean that for david i
mean that for clyde i mean that for my
team i mean that for the people that
we're going to meet there
i'm going to do everything i can to make
sure that the restaurants that i go to
flourish and that the bartenders and the
waiters are tipped well and that people
are happy there and i miss that and that
is something that we all had we all had
it
they took it from us and then maybe we
just gave too much at the same time um
but
it's your life man and uh you got to
make the decisions to
do what is best for you that's what
we're doing here uh california in some
ways has been very good to me as i said
earlier we came with nothing we got some
stuff now and i got a good life and all
that um but now it's starting to take
too much can't play that game anymore so
that's it literally as when i say
goodbye to you in in just a sec we're
disassembling the whole thing
and uh and we're getting out of here so
i thank you guys for being part
of my life for the past eight years here
in los angeles but as i say to david
every day this is just the beginning and
i'm incredibly excited
and
let's go brandon
god bless america
keep florida florida
what what does santa say now he keep
what does he say keep my
what's this new thing it's like keep my
florida florida keep america keep stay
the away from me something like
that whatever it is it's like yeah that
whole thing
anyway really guys thank you and all
right we got a lot of work to do you
know what
you know what
we're getting guacamole on the chipotle
today that's the final thing that i will
say in this studio guacamole for
everybody see you guys in a couple weeks
if you want to play along in the
meantime reubenreport.locals.com
and truly i appreciate you thank you and
this is just the beginning